bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got bobby
here we're basically just going to talk
[ __ ] the entire time
and tell everyone if you don't live in
miami you should move here immediately
just kidding uh what's up man how are
you i'm great and uh are we kidding like
because i think people should move here
to miami i think they should too we will
get to miami in a second
uh what did you do before you moved to
miami um
and what out of school you worked at
facebook first uh i did yeah anyways
thanks pomp for having me
and uh yeah so my background is i'm a
product designer by by trade
um right out of school i worked at
facebook i was one of the first product
designers there
i was their first designer on the user
growth team so i designed a lot of
facebook's
kind of onboarding and registration
systems so if you sign up for facebook
kind of 2008-2012 give or take you
probably use some of my interfaces
and um yeah that's kind of where i
started out my career so i worked on the
uh on the growth team at facebook that's
right i know very
a lot of the same people that's right
they are fantastic it's probably the
best growth team in
the world i would say i think you would
probably agree yeah
um but you left in 2012.
i did okay what was the thought process
between
uh i'm here at facebook things are going
great and then you leave to go do other
stuff what like what
drew you away yeah i mean look to be
honest like facebook
just completely changed my life it was a
incredible opportunity and and that that
user growth team
in particular was just pretty legendary
you know when i first
joined the company it was not the
sexiest assignment to get
you know i was joining as a new designer
and people wanted to work on
you know the stuff that's like front and
center the news feed
the profiles photos and to work on the
user growth team is like
not the most exciting assignment but it
kind of turned out that that
team was this this fairly legendary team
we kind of invented in
a lot of new uh design patterns for how
to how to build these social networks
um but yeah and then i i spent about
four and a half years at facebook
um totally incredible place and
um you know honestly i was um i was
extremely excited to start
uh angel investing and um even had a
specific investment in mind that i
wanted to make but
but i couldn't and at the time um
you know in 2012 if you wanted to um
do angel investing um you weren't really
allowed to as
an employee at the company now people
still did and i found that out after the
fact that that people kind of
broke the rules and just didn't tell
anybody and so maybe had that
uh been been known to me i maybe would
have done things differently but but
yeah so i kind of left to start
my investing career and and you know
kind of
in retrospect i i think uh was fortunate
i
i left when i did but um again like i
owe
facebook just the world because it
really launched my career
i'm in the exact same boat i feel like i
learned so much at facebook
uh given that the user growth team at
facebook
literally we can joke all we want be
like oh they're the best like they
legitimately are the best in the world
at this
uh what are some of the things you took
away from working with that team
and many of the leadership of that team
is still there at facebook literally
a decade later right so what were some
of the takeaways for you
um yeah i mean that's a great question i
think like
some of the takeaways were just um ways
of thinking about how to design
new user experiences for um
for startups so um you know we came up
with this idea i remember
we called it the aha moment which is
that uh you know when a user is signing
for facebook they might be
struggling through all these all these
all these forms we throw their way so we
kind of ask them for all this
information and it's kind of a lot of
work
um and then i remember we we this one
user test back in the day where we had
we had someone come in
and she was kind of suffering through
the the status quo of the onboarding
flow
and then all of a sudden kind of got to
this one screen which was the screen
where
we could show the user here's here's
these folks that
you might know so based on the
information she gave
us we could we could show potential
friends from
from high school from college from from
her hometown and just kind of this grid
of faces
and then we were i remember we were
watching this and we had like an eye
tracking computer that could
see where her eyes were looking on the
screen and then she kind of got to this
step
and and by the way had she not been in
the user testing lab
she probably would have just given up
because she had to go through all these
error states and it was quite a
quite a mess to get here but she got to
the screen and then all of a sudden her
eyes kind of darted to the friends she
knew
and then her eyes like lit up she kind
of leaned into the computer or she was
like
oh wow okay i understand the value of of
what
of what facebook is and so
that idea actually got us to completely
re-architect the onboarding flow for
facebook so we reordered steps we took
things that were kind of
um these really onerous steps like
confirming our email account
and we put those as far back in the
process as we possibly could
with with the idea of like how do we how
do we kind of um
um uh back load the the work behind
um the point where the users are like
really sold on the value of the product
and so like so that was kind of like one
i guess i guess we kind of we gave a
talk about
this idea and we kind of you know showed
the um
kind of before and after how much of
this is like you just tested a million
things that eventually saw this realized
it and then like execute
on it versus this was like a
preconceived almost
thesis and then that's why you ran us
like
this specific test yeah so um
a lot of the ladders a little bit of the
former you know there are other
cases where for example we had this
registration
form uh which was like the primary form
that that
everyone signed up to facebook through
circa 2008 give or take
and uh it had been a b tested to death
by all these different pms and someone
said okay
what if we what if we kind of put this
um you know
instruction text here and what if we put
this you know
this sub header here and if we kind of
put clarifying text here and there
and then basically over time the the
form had just been kind of
um you know layered upon layered upon
and each successive test
had actually gotten to a point where it
actually marginally improved the numbers
but then
you know one of the one of the one of
the funny things about
the success i had at facebook was that
um
in one afternoon um myself and this ui
engineer
we were like fed up with this forum we
were like this thing sucks like let's
let's redesign it and so i kind of just
did a very
basic uh cleanup of this thing uh he he
built it we had the thing test overnight
and in on the course of like 24 hours we
were able to
increase the top level registration rate
of facebook
and this is like in 2008 uh by something
like five percent
just by like cleaning up a bunch of of
kind of
a b test nonsense and so and so
sometimes you have you had these kind of
really easy wins that were just like hey
let's just apply
some some very basic design
sensibilities towards this
other times it was more like hey let's
let's really zoom out and look at what
what the
the bigger barriers are here like how do
we how do we kind of
how do we do these bigger architecture
projects um
but um but yeah i mean i think i think
it was just a very experimental
team and then also one where the the
sort of eyes the rest of the company
were off of us so we could we could
really get away with a lot and just like
continually run a lot of tests where you
know if we wanted to put
an obnoxiously big green button on
things that maybe the other designers
would be like yeah
maybe you shouldn't ship that
obnoxiously large screen button
um but but they didn't really see these
flows because they weren't signing up
for new accounts or they weren't using
you know the blank states of of of our
of our of our apps and so um
we were able to kind of get away with a
lot of things and and and test a lot of
things and
along the way we actually really
invented a lot of new uh design patterns
so uh when i was at facebook i was
running the growth team for facebook
pages
and uh you were doing this 2008 2009
this is now
uh probably 2014 when i'm doing this and
one of the big wins that we had
was uh on the um kind of
mobile web like the m web or whatever uh
for really really old non-smartphone
phones right so kind of things where you
would have to like click almost like a
t9 style
uh there would be a header and so it
would be things like you know
home profile whatever and you would have
to click through to get to it
and so we literally one time moved
create page from like the 27th slot to
like
slot eight and all of a sudden there was
an explosion in the creation of pages
and everyone was like oh my god this is
like amazing and i remember somebody on
the team being like
no one's ever tested this because nobody
uses those phones right right
at facebook like like that's such an
obscure thing we forget how much
traffic and how many users use that very
obscure thing and so
what you just said about this kind of
registration page that's also very
unique to facebook and was unique in
2008 but became even more unique over
time
was just the volume right so you could
run this test
and 24 hours later have a statistically
significant result
that you knew as long as you ran that
test correctly right
hey is it better or is it not whereas a
startup or somebody else
it could take them two months to get
enough data right right at facebook you
got it in 24 hours and so that iteration
speed
was just a complete superpower i think
for the growth team yeah
and one of the one of the takeaways from
that
that i've applied to some of the
companies i've worked with uh
since facebook is that there's a basic
idea that
the interfaces that the employee base of
your company use
so so if you're you're on the team
you're kind of using the product day in
and
out those interfaces tend to get refined
and optimized just kind of
naturally by the very course of
employees kind of going about their way
if there's a bug
if there's a bug in kind of the core
workflow of your product and employees
are using that workflow every day
it'll naturally get fixed but there's
always these interfaces
that employees don't use all the time
right so sign up flows are like the
biggest category of this
blank states where it's like what
happens when there's no data in the
system
and and how to users interface with that
these things break
constantly and like that was one of the
big takeaways from working on that team
at facebook which is like
we constantly had to do this cleanup
work where
everything that was in the eyes of the
employee base was just
totally scrutinized and cleaned up and
optimized um later in my career at
facebook i was the lead designer for
facebook photos and like
i i redesigned the photo viewer um and
we we kind of iterated in front of the
whole company we shipped a new version
of the photo viewer like every single
night for
for about a month and like believe like
every every little detail gets
scrutinized right but
but when i was on the user growth team
we were changing the sign up flow for
the product
which is actually far more important if
you think about it than than like you
know where the buttons
go on on the photo viewer no one had any
feedback whatsoever because they didn't
use it
and so that that that lesson has
has very much stuck with me and it's
actually almost a cheat code
when i when i work with some of the
companies i work with now once they're
at a
kind of an established point um you know
i think i think
one of the things you can just tell them
is like have your employees go back and
like
you know use the interfaces that they're
not regularly using so have them sign up
for the product again and again and
again have them
go through that new user experience
again and again and again and
things will naturally get refined things
will naturally
evolve one of the things that i remember
taking away from that team specifically
was this idea that
every single test in order to know if
you're right or not
you have to perfectly execute and then
be right
and the reason why perfect execution of
the way that the the test is designed is
so important
is because if you design a test and then
you screw up the execution and it
doesn't work
you're left wondering was it the
execution of the test that was wrong
or was actually the thing we were
testing doesn't work right
and i think that that's when you get
into this like very kind of testing
heavy growth heavy type environment
uh there's plenty of people who yell and
scream and say it's horrible they're at
least the bad things whatever
but at the end of the day as a as a
science as a way to use software to
grow the metrics of a business bar none
nothing beats that right in terms of the
actual adherence to
truth and the seeking of truth right yes
and kind of this belief that like the
code wins the argument or the data wins
the argument
and i think that's probably the thing
that you took away from facebook and i
definitely took away
was just like that organization and that
team specifically is
um i think unrivaled in their like
pursuit of that truth
yes and i think it gave me a very good
anchoring
in product design as a as a discipline i
think a lot of folks
think about design in a very
um unserious way they think about it as
this more artistic pursuit it's about
making things look pretty
and i've never really had that attitude
i've i've always
had the mindset design is about solving
problems it's about
kind of taking in a set of constraints
and and and coming up with the solution
that satisfies all those constraints
and then i think in an environment like
that early
facebook uh user growth team that
that really forces one to to to say okay
is my design
solving the problem that's on the on the
table here and we should be able to
measure that and i think
um that designers should really welcome
that
that level of instrumentation and that
level of metrics
so i think this is after you left the
data point that i always tell people to
kind of hint at like just
how data-driven the organization is is
this is now
2015 i think they were trying to measure
sentiment
on facebook and how do you
move sentiment how do you measure that
right so what they essentially did was
they created a metric called
cow cau and it was the response to a
survey question that was does facebook
care about users so it cares about user
cau
and what they would do is they would
basically show you various experiences
or products or functionality or whatever
and then they would hit you with the uh
survey right and they had surveyed you
before
and then they survey you after and what
was so fascinating about this
was they could not move the freaking
metric interesting they could not move
it right and so
i'm getting like a crash course in this
and i'm like this is absolutely
fascinating right you have what is not a
data-driven problem it's usually more of
like a psychological
uh or sentiment driven problem but
they're trying to measure it
and so what ultimately ended up being
one of like the the breakthroughs of
this entire
uh exercise was uh somebody put an
interest uh interstitial at the top
at of the um uh kind of news feed and i
forget what it was
a happy birthday or whatever but they
signed it
from all of us at facebook from all of
us at facebook
survey bam cow moves is metric for the
first time
oh interesting and everyone was like
whoa whoa what was it like what moved
you know and and you can just imagine
like now i'll send like there's movement
right and everyone's getting really
excited and trying to figure it out
and so they pinned it down to from all
of us at facebook
that one phrase ended up moving
sentiment and
and increasing people's belief that
facebook cared about the user right
and so in hindsight i remember looking
back and saying like
wow you never there is no path that you
get to other than
pure uh probability just working in your
favor
of coming up with facebook from all of
us at facebook
that would endear a more positive view
of a company
unless you have that data-driven
approach and you're actually measuring
things and doing all this
but it's the adherence to like such a
data-driven approach
that not only makes facebook facebook
but it's what led to billions of users
using the product right and and things
that you did on the design side go hand
in hand with that which i don't think
people really
kind of think of design and data really
being the way that uh that it works
yeah it's actually funny you um kind of
mention that um the change of a
messaging tone
because you know way back in the day
we had we had some philosophies around
what the voice of facebook should be
like and it wasn't
it wasn't that tone that you described
it's actually far more
you know like this is meant to be more
like an operating system and less like a
person
speaking to you and i i kind of i had
left the company at this point but i do
remember like
at a certain point uh you know call it
2014 2015
where i started seeing different um
different styles of messaging coming
from facebook speaking to users i was
like hang on it's like what's going on
here and so there you go that's the
explanation
close the loop for you yeah all right so
you leave facebook 2012
um and you want to go invest uh i know
the story so i'm cheating but tell us
the story about like
what are the first two investments that
you go do yeah well the first one was a
payments company which which um
i think i was in the right um the right
general
uh strike area but didn't hit didn't it
stripe a second one
i was fortunate enough to invest in into
coinbase
and so that was my second ever angel
investment i was actually
uh not liquid in the seed round uh
in 2012 but um uh as soon as i
kind of became liquid from facebook uh
in in at the start of 2013 i made my
second ever angel investment into into
coinbase okay how do you find
coinbase why do you know that hey i
should do this and then explain this
hunting process that you went through to
track it down
yeah yeah i mean it's a great and it's
something where i think like as an
investor i think it's really important
to like study
what your circle of competence is how do
you find deals
and and try to remember those things
with like a certain amount of clarity so
like
these days i write deal memos with every
investment i make so that when i look
back in time i can remember
what my thought process was like when i
made the investment back then
unfortunately i didn't do these things
but but yeah i mean i was basically
a little bit of a bitcoin nerd in 2012
um and um was it was in
the r slash bitcoin subreddit
and and i think you know had bought my
first bitcoins
had to buy them through mount gox for
those of us who remember
mount gox and um and i i really do think
that um
um for me when coinbase came around
it felt more like an obvious um
an obvious improvement relative to mount
cox i think for anyone who is who is in
the community at that time
who had kind of suffered through the
terrible user experience of mount cox
uh to contrast that with with what
coinbase offered was was really quite
quite compelling and so that that's kind
of become one of my
thesis around how do i find these new
breakout companies
i like to call it communities which see
the future so
and i think i've been maybe part of two
of these maybe three of these throughout
my career so
the first one was was with facebook
where i was lucky enough to be a college
student when
facebook started and so i think if you
were in college at the time
when it was college only no one outside
of colleges could use facebook
um we all had this sort of glimpse of
the future
and if you'd asked people in college in
you know 2006 2007 like hey do you think
everyone's going to start using this
facebook thing
they would probably say yes versus if
you talk to somebody
who who's on the outside who didn't know
access to facebook they might just
scratch their heads and not really
understand what you're talking about and
so
so i think like there's this you know
there's this famous quote by william
gibson
uh the future is already here it's just
not evenly distributed
and i think of that in like very literal
terms so when i was in when i was in
college i was i was kind of fortunate
enough to be in this bubble of the
future which used
facebook and then it became somewhat of
a foregone conclusion to us inside of
that bubble like hey
this is going to expand to encompass a
lot more people maybe everybody
and then and then i had a similar
feeling with um
with bitcoin in 2012 and and with
coinbase in particular which is like
well i thought bitcoin was kind of this
bubble of the future unto itself
but then even within that i thought hey
like it just seems pretty obvious to me
that like people are gonna use
coinbase over something like mount gox
and so at a minimum like
this thing has some legs in terms of uh
getting onto that
level of market share now did i know in
2013 that
it would it would ultimately rise to
where it is today no
but um but i think that that lens of
like
you know what which kind of bubbles of
the future am i privy to
you know what what part of the future am
i seeing that is maybe yet to be
distributed to everybody
and i think like for a lot of folks if
you really if you really kind of spend
some time thinking about it you can
actually come up with some pretty
interesting answers
yeah and when you start to think about
how to identify that
do you have to be in the community to
know that that community knows something
or is it possible for an outsider to
understand yeah i mean
obviously it helps right and and um
and uh there is something about that
you know kind of kind of first hand
experience where where
um you kind of feel like a bit like an
underdog and
you just know this thing's gonna uh get
going gonna
do really well and then you see these
people on the outside just don't quite
get it and
there's something quite special about
that but yeah i do think that
um you can sort of systematically hunt
for
folks who have um who are part of these
communities of the future
um um it's it's a little bit more
difficult because i do
i do really feel like um at least for
myself
my own experience i think that the best
wins are going to come from where
you can um authentically engage in
something and actually get genuinely
curious and excited about it i think
like one of my criticisms
well this isn't a criticism per se of of
kind of the venture capital world but
like
it's one of my dissatisfactions with how
some folks approach
the space which is i think i think
people don't get genuinely excited about
the things they invest in
right and um when when someone like
truly um finds something they actually
care about and
they really just get fired up about it
like that's that's almost rare and when
someone's a professional investor and
they're kind of
you know tasked with with hunting down
these things and
and and and kind of putting out a number
of investments on a regular interval
um i think that that passion that that
um
that falling into that that that that
that special community that sees the
future like that doesn't happen
that's a more rare feeling um and so
even when you're like when you're um
when you're when you're professional
investor when you're
uh getting a lot of inbound deal flow
it's very hard to get
you know deeply immersed in everything
you're seeing because you're you're
seeing so many pitches back to back to
back
um but then i you know for my
personal successes in my in my career
each one has really fit this pattern of
like yeah i was kind of
part of this this early community of
folks that uh
that really saw the future and uh
like it was almost a sure thing to us
when we were inside that bubble
so how do you go from bitcoin is
going to be a thing to i'm an investor
in coinbase like what's the actual
process
yeah i mean um maybe this is also
my design background uh coming into play
here but um
um i really uh i really biased towards
uh thoughtfully designed interfaces um
interfaces that reduce friction um if
you you have to ask me like what's the
what's the easiest way
what's the most straightforward way to
make a product that's 10 times
better i think an answer that i would
give you although it's like kind of
easier said than done
answer is um just just create a 10
times better user experience right and
again it's easier said than done
answer so for example one of my
companies uh these days is a company
called linear
and they're uh their competitor to jira
the
the task management productivity tool
company and there's like a million
little reasons why i could tell you why
linear is like so much better than jira
and it's very hard to put your finger on
it but i think they all kind of sum up
to this experience that is
actually 10 times better so design is
kind of this cheat code in some ways to
to creating a product that is uh
meaningfully better than
than an incumbent product that was
certainly the case with coinbase
relative to mount gox back in the day
and again you could kind of like you
could kind of document every single
reason why
um you know and in retrospect the big
reason why is because bangkok's turned
out to be a scam but um
um um that helps when you're not a scam
and your competitor is a scam
yeah it turns out that's a good that's a
good competitive advantage
um but yeah i mean i i generally think
that like focusing on user experience
focusing on design really matters um i
think especially in
financial services companies like
coinbase where um design is kind of a
shortcut to communicating trust
so you know even before we knew mount
gox was a scam
it kind of just screamed scam when you
looked at it because
the design was was terrible it just
looked like something that was a scam
and so if you start from a point where
you actually have thoughtful considerate
design
um that that communicates to a user a
certain degree of trust
and then and then you just have to make
good on it not being a scam part and
then and then you're good so
step one is don't create a scam step two
is don't make it look like a scam
right right right and i can't help you
if if it is a scam i'm not gonna help
you with step two but like
yeah i mean but when you see coinbase
and you're like okay this is beautifully
designed right i think what's so
fascinating is my understanding is a
number of the best investments you've
made
it was not like somebody called you up
and was like hey bobby we're like doing
a fundraising round like do you want to
participate
you were just starting out as an
investor and so you had to go hunting
you had to go get an introduction to the
founder you had to go and convince them
to take your money like walk through
that process and
and why you were so willing to go do the
work to go hunting
and this is something that's like really
high on my mind right now because
as i've evolved in my career as an
investor i kind of naturally get more
inbound deal flow like i get i get a lot
of people sending me deals right now
and then i always have to balance that
against the fact that
hey my best deal i ever did was not a
deal that flowed to me
it was a deal that i found out about and
i go i went and knocked on the door and
got into the deal
i would call that spear phishing right
and i think
in in venture capital in general we talk
a lot about deal flow
and we think about deal flow as like so
much of a part of the game that you you
know
but i i honestly think that um
it can be a double-edged sword and um
i think i think some investors do better
in different environments and so
for myself like when i was first
starting out as an investor
nobody knew who i was no one was sending
me deals i got no deal flow
but what that does is that affords a
certain amount of
kind of white space where i can get
genuinely excited about things i could
spend all these hours on r
bitcoin i didn't have pitch meeting
after pitch meeting to get
to take up my time and so you could find
this genuine curiosity as genuine
excitement
and then oh well here you go like here's
this new company
coinbase i've been in this community for
a few months
mount cox is terrible i really need to
do anything i can to go
to go get into this deal and and i i
think that that
that mode of spearfishing is is a
really compelling alternative to this
idea of um you know i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna have this gravitational
pull of deal flow and have everyone come
pitch me
when what did you do to get an
introduction to brian yeah yeah so
again i i leaned heavily on my
background as a designer
and i had a i had a friend of ours um
make an introduction and um you know
basically i i spent um two or three
uh sessions in the office just like
helping them on their their new user
account flows on some very basic
kind of um onboarding um interfaces for
for
very early coinbase and then i said hey
you know look i just made my first
angel investment i'd love to make my
second one into this like can i can i
get into the next round and they said
sure no problem
and i think that idea of um of um
of of offering something very specific
in my case like
a very a very minor amount of design
support which wind up kind of widening
and
over the years i helped them recruit a
couple designers i connected them to two
different design firms
uh later did like a more intensive uh
onboarding review for
for them and and then they they kind of
rewarded me with that with with allowing
me to invest
uh you know more capital into later
rounds and then ultimately
uh was able to raise an spv into the
last round before they went public
and um just all by on the all by the
virtue of um
kind of spending a little bit of time
and help helping them with something
that i was i was kind of uh
you know relevant and informed to help
them about and so when you
think about that deal and when you
deployed capital
obviously you're gonna have some
hindsight bias but do you think it's a
50 billion dollar company or do you
think it's like hey maybe they can you
know grow and they'll get bought at 100
million
like what's kind of the upper bound of
what you think that potential investment
has at the time
yeah and that's like so i don't think i
was i think if i'm being honest i didn't
have these sorts of um thought exercises
fully established in my head as an
investor when i did it but that's
part of how i think about investing now
which is um i think a really important
question wherever you see
an opportunity is um you have to ask
yourself like
what if what if this goes perfectly
right uh which i know sounds like a
silly thing to say
and and um it might seem particularly
naive
for for uh silicon valley investors say
something like that
um but i think um i think the default
for most people
is that they default to uh cynicism and
skepticism
and when you pitch someone a new idea i
think most people will start shooting
down the reasons why
it won't work and those are really
important to capture and like as an
investor you need to have
that skepticism you need to be able to
do that level of
you know intellectual rigor you need to
apply that towards the idea but but
before you do any of that i think it's
really
important just to imagine that um you
know kind of unicorns and rainbows
scenario where everything goes right
and what that does is that it it
basically lets you ask the question like
how much
will this like where does this where's
this uh peter out like where does this
end and i think for for many ideas
um you will find you you will come up
with some kind of cap
where you say okay i think if this thing
goes really well this is this kind of
enterprise sas
company and i think it could get to this
level of recurring revenue and that
would make
it worth this amount of money and this
is what the world looks like when
everything goes right for this company
and when you could find yourself coming
with
a very concrete cap and and thereby kind
of coming up with a
a pretty concrete um expected value
calculation about it
i tend to shy away from those things
versus
going after things that i think have
potentially uncapped outcomes where when
i start
assessing okay okay what if this thing
starts going right and like okay
and then with something like coinbase
and with bitcoin in general
you start getting into these scenarios
in your head where
really you have to start thinking about
like how governments are going to start
responding to this thing and that's
that's a really good sign
when you start to if it's big enough for
the government to be worried about it
then you probably did it right as an
investor
yeah like that that probably enters in
this uncapped category outcome
and um and and yeah i think
um those are worth worth we have because
again it all comes back
this sort of i like to call it a fuzzy
expected value calculus where
again like i think a lot of the a lot of
mistakes a lot of investors make are
that they're kind of
overly scrutinous of ideas they kind of
shoot them down and then the only thing
the only thing that gets to the filter
are these more
capped outcomes they're more sure bets
and um
you know when they when they work that
sure they can they can result in some
great outcomes
um but what i found in practice is that
um
you know the the failure rate between
the um
these sort of kind of smaller base hit
capped outcomes
and the failure rate between that and
these um
kind of grand slam um you know launch
the ball into orbit
outcomes um it's actually not terribly
different
and if you're going to take the risk on
investing in something that can go to
zero and that
that takes on a lot of the same style of
risks regardless of what the startup is
uh you might as well like really swing
really swing for the fences
yeah one of the things that to me is
just absolutely fascinating
is uh being rational is actually
a hindrance to making good investments
because what you're essentially doing is
you're looking for something that's
doing something different
and right and so it's an outlier and
therefore it's irrational
and so if you're a rational person
evaluating something from a rational
standpoint
in most cases you're going to miss the
absolute most asymmetric things
right you're definitely going to find
things that are less likely to lose
money so it's you know
low probability of losing money or lower
probability but the
upside is capped the more irrational you
are actually the higher
the asymmetry is but the lower
probability of success and as a venture
investor you want the latter
you don't want the uh the former yeah
yeah or like
i also i also think that um things that
might
feel really irrational um can actually
you can flip over in your head to having
a real
rational belief in them if you can just
get past this like one
like immediate point of skepticism which
is
again why i think i think it's almost a
cliche
in if you talk if you talk to folks who
work at these larger venture capital
firms and they kind of hire um you know
like a junior person to come onto the
team
and they go to their first partner
meeting it's almost like cliche
that this new person will just like
start firing out all these reasons why
uh the idea that's on on the on the
table will fail
and it's really easy to do that it's
actually like it's and i think like it's
table stakes for any investor
is to be able to kind of come up with
this list of of um
of criticisms and like it's it and it's
it's a very again it's a very it sounds
very silly to say this but i think
it actually is a worthwhile mental
exercise to just like put those
to the side and say what if everything
goes right and like
let's just pretend for a moment what
does that scenario look like because at
least that gives you
this this like upside calculation where
you could start to get this fuzzy
expected value calculation
because again like the downside risk of
all these things is the same
you're the downside risk is you lose all
your money um
and so when when you when you find one
of these things where you just can't
even imagine how big the upside case is
even if the odds are quite slim
it it tends those tend to be things
worth swinging at especially when you're
constructing a
you know a balanced portfolio when you
think about
uh investing you obviously
are good at it you've had a number of
hits uh you now have started an actual
fund right form capital we can talk
about that
uh what is it that you enjoy about this
like why do you enjoy why did you not go
and
join another company and say hey i'm
gonna go find you know facebook 2.0
and um and kind of go do this all over
again why have you spent so much time
investing
well part of it is that i think i'm a
bit scatterbrained i really do enjoy
um going from um working on healthcare
startups working on a crypto startup to
working
on um uh you know a social game
and uh i like i like as a designer i i
really love getting involved in these
companies
and and kind of just trying on a new set
of problems and seeing how i can i can
resolve them and so
that someone speaks to our model with
this new fund
so we're over a very small seed fund
we're kind of a supporting fund so we
invest alongside
other investors typically um and then
beyond just a check
we offer what we call a design sprint so
with every
with every investment we offer roughly
40 hours of hands-on design support so
we have a small team of designers
on staff that that works with our
founders
and that's what makes it interesting to
me because
if if i was just kind of writing a check
and giving a wave bye bye i think
i think it wouldn't be as meaningful it
wouldn't be as exciting to me wouldn't
be as fulfilling
i think investing in a lot of in a lot
of ways is getting more commoditized
that's a good thing
um and so for myself to kind of make it
exciting to make it interesting
i really want to have that participatory
aspect to it and that's kind of what i
found with this with this new fund
uh the fund structure is very unique in
that
uh you intentionally are keeping the
fund rather small you're intentionally
having a pretty large gp commit
walk through just like why are you doing
things different right than let's say a
traditional fund would do
you obviously you're very well connected
you've got a great track record you
could probably go raise
you know 50 100 million dollar funds
very easily like why
go after this specific strategy right
right so i think there's like there's
kind of two
pieces to the fund one is like the value
add which is very exciting to me it's
kind of the reason why
i do it and then there's the economics
of it and um
the economic side of it also informs um
how i'm thinking about
being an lp and other funds so um i'm an
lp at about 15 different
small seed funds all around the same um
fun size as mine and um i generally have
this
this this this current market thesis
around um seed stage capital which is
that
um obviously we're all seeing an
abundance of
of of capital flow into this environment
um there are a lot of funds that are
lead check writing funds so meaning
they've raised
let's call it between 50 and 80 million
dollars
and when you raise a fund of that size
you wind up having to
invest at a certain check size with
every deal
and uh you know typically that for a
seed fund that would be something on the
order of like
a million five per deal and what i've
seen
just firsthand is
there's a lot of competition to be that
lead investor i think there's a certain
degree of
uh adverse selection challenges that
come with that in other words
um if you can't be the lead investor
uh it's a it's a binary proposition
you're either in the deal or you're not
uh versus these smaller fund managers
and angel investors who put in these
these smaller checks um let's say they
put in a
200k check as opposed to a 1.5 million
dollar check
um they tend to get access to the deals
they want to invest in
and when they want to deploy an amount
of capital into a deal they tend to
secure that allocation
um versus someone writing running a lead
fund may more often than
the smaller investor get rebuffed
entirely or or if the lead investor
says hey i would like to invest a
million five and the founder comes back
to them and says
how about 200k well
that's kind of fatal to that investor
like you can't make the fund math
work on an investment that size versus
if someone who's running a smaller fund
comes to them and says hey i'd like 300k
and the fund manager comes back says how
about 200 well you can kind of make that
work and still return the entire fund
and so
when i think about um how to structure
um both my lp checks throughout the
industry
um and also how to structure my own fund
in terms of like
how do i how do i maximize the returns
that i want to
pursue i think it's really important to
be able to invest every time i want to
be able to invest and i think if you're
running a lead fund in seed
you need to have a very i think you need
to be very
very honest with yourself and ask
yourself am i able to invest
every time i want to invest and i i i'm
increasingly seeing
uh that answer as no
and um again i think like some of these
some of these uh seed funds that i'm l
peeing are probably some of the smartest
investment checks
i'll ever write i actually feel i feel
very similarly about
the lp checks that i'm writing right now
as i did about
the angel checks i wrote eight years ago
it has a very similar um
kind of feeling to me about it um and um
i kind of like this this strategy we
call it like a nano fund strategy
um what does that mean uh sub 15 million
dollar funds
got it so sub 15 million dollars not
lead
how many companies on average do you
think go into these funds
it depends our our structure is a little
bit more weighted
in that we like to put kind of um more
wood behind fewer arrows but i've
invested in other
smaller managers who do you know 60 60
deals per fund which i think is too much
but
but even so it's a it's a very big
difference to me when you're when you're
able to get the allocation you ask for i
think that's it's almost like the most
critical thing in terms of being a fund
manager where it's like
it's it's like when you talk about
investing
you know you kind of have to um see the
deal
right you have to say yes to the deal
and then you have to win the deal and um
you know let's just say that you know
those first two things are
somewhat somewhat table stakes in the
sense that like okay you have to have
you have to have good deal flow or kind
of know where to look
and um you have to have good judgment
and you have to say yes to the thing
that's going to work
um this latter category is like is so
much
in control by the structure of how you
how you run your business right
again if you know investing is is
is um you know startup investing is like
one of the few
uh forms of investing where the asset
picks the manager
right what do you mean by that well
again it's it's not enough
for me to say oh i think this startup's
really great i'm gonna go invest in it
well they might tell you
well great there's no allocation for you
right or we don't like you or we don't
like you or any other things right
so and so and so i think a lot of a lot
of um
investors focus on things like um
again like how do i maximize deal flow
how do i how do i think about picking
skills
i think a really important quality of
any good investors
they're being picked skill right and
then there's like i think there's
the two dimensions i can think of
offhand to optimize for that is like
um have something valuable to offer you
know
we've kind of we've kind of gone with
this design value offering and we think
that's compelling
and then two like you know just
structurally position yourself such that
you can
you can be accommodated into these
rounds and when you have to eat up the
whole thing
well that's just going to limit the
number of opportunities you can pursue
and so
hopefully one of those lead checks you
know a lead writer will
write will wind up you know kind of um
being the grand slam they hope it is but
but for myself for my style of investing
i really like to structure myself in a
way where where i'm focused on like
finding things i really enjoy that i
really want to invest in
and i don't like optimizing for like
doing this battle royale with some other
startup investor like who's going to
lead the deal like i don't want to get
into that competition
and so and nor do i want the fount the
um the fund managers that i back to be
involved in that competition i'd rather
just kind of
get into everything interesting and and
kind of
i think i think go um you know kind of
an inch deep in a mile wide
in in in this category when you think
about
um crypto
it's something that seems like you're
dabbling a little bit in
it's intellectually stimulating the
design is
horrendous right we spent a lot of time
talking about early stage investing
crypto is everything we just talked
about on steroids
asymmetry uh weirdness you know all this
kind of stuff
what is going on with the design the
user experience the user interface is
like
one why is it so atrocious and two like
do you expect it to get better
well it is getting better and like i
think and again
um maybe this is you know me having a
hammer and
thinking everything is a nail but i can
really
track the the ease of use of crypto and
i think i think runs in complete
correlation with the
mainstream adoption of it as as you've
seen
either either companies or um
or projects that have extended um
extended the user base of crypto i think
they all have one thing in common which
is they
they tend to be well designed they tend
to be they tend to value user experience
and i think there's there's there's a
few cases of like
some more esoteric highly technical
use cases evolving that um i think can
be very financially lucrative and that
can drive adoption as well but we're
talking about like
the mainstream um general public
adopting crypto
uh i think design has almost always been
the limiting factor and will kind of
continue to be for a long time and so
again that's that's why it was very
exciting for me to back coinbase back in
the day because i saw that as like this
this really enabling factor for crypto
overall and i think
a lot of folks in crypto really have a
bias towards thinking about
um the technology the protocols the the
um
you know the kind of technical
developments going on in the space is
like that's
that's what's that's what's creating the
the
the adoption but i think you really have
to give credit to folks that
that that make this easy to use that
that make it accessible to everybody
folks like coinbase um who have
brought so many more people into the
crypto universe
is that probably the number one limiting
factor to more mainstream adoption is
just the user experience the user
interfaces of these products
i think so and and i think um
i think in general like design tends to
um you know follow behind the the
technical
development in other words like there's
a few projects where
um i think i think the end user
experience becomes a goal at which the
the technology gets warped to
accommodate but that's kind of the
exception not the norm
in other words like the technology is
kind of created as it as it exists
and then it's up to the designers to try
to
you know bang this thing into shape to
actually make it easy to use
and i think i think some of the you know
some of the most exciting
projects that i see on the horizon are
ones that really think about
like how do we make this easy to use
from from the get-go
and it feels almost like the idea of
crypto is so
antithetical to like the way people have
thought historically that
already you're asking people to make a
big leap on like the philosophical or
kind of the point of whatever the
product or services
and so the more you can make the design
uh in some ways similar to what they're
used to right being user
uh very user friendly being easy to
quickly sign up being able to understand
hey if i click on that tray i know
exactly what the action is going to be
inside the app like that seems to be in
some ways missing
but also like the lowest hanging fruit
again earlier you said like this idea of
like
design is the fastest way to kind of
build trust or or
signal trust in crypto like where else
do you need that with some of these
products than
you know that industry right right and
um yeah i mean i think i think um
oftentimes it's it's a it's a smart idea
to maybe build an interface that um
that borrows heavily on um kind of a
mainstream
uh financial interface that folks might
already be familiar with
that that maybe has to be a bit
shoehorned into crypto but but but
if it's something that people can
immediately grok and understand like
it's it's almost worth
having that um that simplification that
reduction
just in order to get people to
understand it and i think i think
sometimes we build
uh we really reinvent the wheel we build
highly technical interfaces when
uh a more simplistic reductive interface
maybe something that hides some of the
options that people don't
necessarily need to tweak um is gonna be
the better choice
and how much of um what you're looking
at in crypto is like
infrastructure so like coinbase is an
exchange the piece of infrastructure
there's hundreds of other pieces of
infrastructure versus more like
protocols tokens and like what i'll
consider like
more of the extreme end of crypto that's
not necessarily infrastructure it's kind
of more of the clinical
new stuff right well i'm looking at a
smattering of things
right now um at the moment
i have like very specific um
there's like specific apps that i want
to exist
and i'm like hunting for those do you
want to share them so that people can
come inbound or no um
um you don't have to yeah i mean um
give us one yeah yeah so um
and i'm already looking at some things
in this category as well so
so i don't necessarily need a bunch of
inbound pitches
but but please you know bobby at form
capital.com please
drop me a line um so if you think about
bitcoin as creating
a sense of digital scarcity and
obviously there's a financial product
attached to that of
with bitcoins i think something
about this whole nft explosion that's
excited me is this idea of
can we take objects
in the physical world that already have
real world scarcity
and can we digitize them can we
financialize them
and so for example um collectible cars
uh trading cards collectible watches
these things
in a sense already have a scarcity
algorithm if you will in other words
in 1952 mercedes made only so many
300 sl gullwing cars right and so the
the the minting for that for that car
has already happened
in the past and so as as
as you look at at digital currencies as
sort of this means of creating
artificial scarcity and then mapping a
financial instrument
to that can we take actually scarce
physical objects and then pair them with
a digital token
uh maybe a fractionalized digital token
and then make that into a
financial instrument so that's that's
like one thing that i'm kind of broadly
interested in that's really trying to
anchor physical goods in the digital
world but still be able to prove
uh kind of provenance over it and also
the
the scarcity uh the who originally made
it
created it where to trade hands etc but
it's a physical item not a digital item
but the digital world still
kind of uh respects or acknowledges the
physical item
yeah and i think like in terms of um
this becoming an asset class i think um
you know maybe a lot of your listeners
would agree that gold is sort of under
fire as as
as taking this this hedging position in
people's portfolios and something like
bitcoin
offers a pretty interesting alternative
but i can even imagine a future
where there's a basket of actually
scarce
kind of provably scarce goods some of
them digital some of them physical
that that replace uh what has been gold
maybe gold is a piece of this basket but
it's it's not the entire basket and so
um this this idea of like financializing
scarce assets is interesting to me
all right we're recording in miami we're
in person uh
i think you may be one of the only
people other than like keith and
who who like miami more than i do uh
why did you move to miami and then what
are your thoughts so far
yeah so um well so far it's been it's
been fantastic
as to why i as to why i moved um
i've lived i lived in san francisco for
about 10 years
um and kind of just watched this wave
emerge
starting in last november and kind of
got to the point in december where i was
like you know what this seems pretty fun
um a lot of people i respect are coming
here
why not take a bit of a flyer on this
and then if i don't like it i can kind
of you know go back within with my tail
between my legs
and um we kind of got here in in january
and have have really just only seen
upside from this have been have just
been uh tremendously happy about the
move
um you know one kind of thought process
i had was
for myself as an investor you know i
could be one of
thousands upon thousands of small new
seed funds in the bay area
or i can be one of a tiny handful here
be part of
this this kind of exciting wave it feels
like very rebellious very
very exciting there's there's a lot of
camaraderie about it
um and um you know have the mayor hype
us up
and um and and i said yeah it's like
it's almost a no-brainer and um again i
really have um
i've really felt very little downside to
the move so far and
a whole ton of upside a lot of friends
of mine kind of told me
you know you'll move here and then
you'll just kind of be kind of bored to
tears or you're gonna
meet all these pretty boring people and
it's been the exact opposite it's like
i've had
i've had interesting person after
district person kind of come into my
life
my my calendar is completely booked like
in terms of
deal flow in terms of um work it's it's
i've never been busier
and that's very much taking me by
surprise and um
it just makes it just kind of makes it
all the more exciting so the two things
i always tell people is one
people who moved here are not moving
here to retire right people are moving
here with a chip on their shoulder and
they're here to work
and uh that alone you can feel the
energy when you're here when you're
meeting with people etc
is that uh the folks who are here are
not gonna stop until this is successful
yeah uh and then two is i think you're
very similar to me and that like i'm
just
happier here yes right and i literally
don't know if it's as stupid as like
it's sunny all the time right and so
therefore you're happy
i don't know if it's because it's a new
place i don't know if it's because
somehow i'm
uh eating healthier food like i i
literally have no clue
right i just know that when i'm here i
feel happier than anywhere else yeah
and that alone is the reason for me to
be like yes i should live here
and we all want to make it work and i
think like that is
like if i had to pitch a founder on
coming here
and and starting their company here as
opposed to the bay area i think that the
camaraderie
and the the kind of um the this like
unified sense of like hey
we're all trying to make this thing
happen
and and so you're you find up getting a
lot of support and contribution from
people who
if this was all back in the bay area
like you know
they wouldn't they wouldn't give you the
time of day but because we're all just
like trying to make this
thing happen um it's really it's really
an awesome feeling it's something i
haven't felt in this industry
um since maybe like 2010 and i
remember like going to you know going to
parties in san francisco like 2011 at
like the
the airbnb people that they had like
house parties like okay
not similar vibes to what i'm feeling
here or like south by southwest circa
2008 where it was a small enough
community you can kind of get to know
people
you can you can i've kind of converted a
lot of um
online friendships to in person
friendships this you know
ourself included and like it's awesome
it's like
um there's honor among thieves right
that's the way i think about it
is we're all in this together right
right and it does feel like a little bit
of a rebellion like it feels
and you know there's there's people who
really
um take umbrage with this um and that
kind of makes it more fun you know i saw
i saw today that um tyler cowan had an
article where he's
you know um not not so excited about
miami being a tech hub i'm like
you know i respect the hell out of tyler
cowan but like
almost the almost the the doubters give
us some some amount of energy
i was gonna say that literally means
we're on to something right right right
right it's kind of like a startup if you
keep hearing no a bunch of times you're
probably on to something right more so
than not
uh if you're right and uh same thing
here it's like the more people yell and
scream
like no it can't happen no it can't
happen it actually convinces me like
it's gonna happen right there's a
certain amount of like self-compounding
narrative to this uh that that that
people who are
uh you know very vigorously against it i
think they don't
fully appreciate how much they
contribute towards it
um um and then i think it just leaves
folks like yourself and me to just be
generally positive about it because
again i'm i'm only seeing positives
and um it's just such a such a fun thing
to be part of and such an easy
uh welcoming community to join uh that
uh it's just a really fun
fun thing to do i couldn't agree more uh
i got three questions before we end
you could ask me one first is what's the
most important book you've ever read
um man i didn't get any no no press
coming yeah so um there's a book called
the denial of death by ernest becker
okay it's kind of a um psychology slash
philosophy book
why is that one stick out to you um
i think it it helps explain and frame
how people think and how um
you know our our mortality is this like
very
uh um interesting motivator and
guiding force for for uh
you know for how we how we view the
world
it's fascinating uh the topic of
mortality and how important that is
right
uh because i think when you get reminded
of that it focuses everything else
right right and so much of our society
is designed and this is what the book
talks about is
is kind of designed to build these
trappings that help you forget about
the fundamental mortality
sleep second question uh comes from our
friends over at eight sleep
yes they have this thermoregulated bed i
sleep on it every night i love it
um i put mine really really cold and i
sleep like a little baby what's your
sleep schedule
now and how has that changed over the
years um
i also have an eat sleep nice
[Laughter]
and it has markedly improved my sleep
so cheers to them and this is becoming a
trend now on the podcast ask this
question
oh i haven't eaten sleep of course and
then they go and they cut the clip and
they put it on
the internet look at how smart we are um
i mean it's probably one of the few
things that actually can make you like
notice notably smarter on a day-to-day
basis just getting a good night's sleep
so yeah it's crazy it literally is crazy
yeah why not what did you used to do did
you sleep like five six hours
were you always a pretty good sleeper
well um again i'm very pro miami so i
don't mean to be
anti-sf but i'll be anti-sf in one
dimension which is
no one has air conditioning in san
francisco and so
i was just sleeping you know sweating
you know sweating bullets and everyone
said oh you're gonna be so
warm here in miami i'm like no no
actually i'm having to adjust to like
set the ac to the right temperature i'm
actually too cold most of the time so i
gotta
adjust that new reality yes uh i love it
being cold
uh most people ask me like you remind me
why do you always wear a hoodie
it's because literally we keep the
office cold yeah look at me man
um last question is aliens are you a
believer or non-believer
um in the um in the science fiction
movie aliens i think it's one of the
best movies of all time
and actually just re-watched it the
other night uh as far as the
um as far as the actual
extraterrestrials
um i don't know i think i think that's
the only fairy answer to give but
all right i sure hope they're not like
the james cameron aliens
um i'm with you i think everyone's with
you yeah that would be bad
that'd one question you have for me um
you know where um so what would you like
to see
happen in miami next like what what's
your vision for the next year
of all this i think just having more
founders start more companies here and
having more success
like i'm a big believer that success but
gets success
and therefore if you have big companies
built here then people will spin out
they'll create their own companies big
exits then people
get capital they can invest and like it
just you start the flywheel
right um it's like that's kind of like a
bland answer frankly but like i think
it's just like blocking and tackling
like hey how do you make a place a tech
hub
same way silicon valley made themselves
a tech hub right like get investment
build big companies start new companies
get investment build big companies and
like and you just start the flywheel
and the next thing you know like the
institutional knowledge of how do you
build big companies
gets built up in a space people come to
that place because they want capital
they want knowledge and they want
workers right
and you're off to the races and so like
we're pretty damn
far down the road already right in terms
of some of the companies that have moved
here
now you just got to start the flywheel
and do more and more and more of it
faster and faster
well we should look at co-investing on a
miami company together because okay
i'm actually some uh maybe i don't wanna
i don't wanna spill the beans here
on camera but like let's let's let's uh
let's work together
i'm just sending my way all right where
can people find you what bobby at form
capital.com bobby form capital.com i'm
at rsg
on twitter and that's about it how did
you get rsg let's have a hold on you
guys those are my initials
i was just really early just really
early got the initials and done
if you want to add me on facebook here's
a here's a flex for the kids at home
right
facebook.com g wow
too bad no one actually uses facebook
usernames for anything
so that was facebook.com
that's pretty good uh but that one's a
total whiff because uh no one
like who cares about facebook usernames
right so i have facebook.com
pomp that's pretty good uh and
at the time when i was working there
they didn't give out the four letter
names
and i like begged i was like come on
like i gotta get it got it
i got it you gotta get it uh and
eventually i got it and i was like yes
and though i can't believe i'm about to
tell the story the way that i convinced
them to give it to me was uh
baz yeah has slash boss b-o-z
and i was like he's got three letters
i'll even take a fourth letter or just
give me slash pomp
so finally i found out who who was doing
it and got it and whatever but slash j
i've never heard of a one letter
there's there are a few of us obviously
there's less than uh less than the
numbers in the alphabet yeah that's the
number of letters in the alphabet i love
it all right and then uh
form capital.com
dot co dot com capital.com yeah all
right awesome man thank you so much for
doing this we'll do it again
this was so fun yeah thanks for having
me